hey youtubers is Charlie and the BBC
just announced Peter Capaldi's news
companion on Doctor Who Samuel Anderson
so I wanted to do a video explaining who
he is and how he's going to change the
core group of Clara and the doctor I'll
also be doing a follow-up Q&A later this
week so subscribe to get it if you're
finding me for the first time I
typically do q and A's for really big
topics like brand new companions so
let's do a quick breakdown of Samuel
Anderson his character's name is Danny
pink and I'll also be a teacher at coal
Hill School with Clara he's most known
for previously co-starring with Coleman
on Emmerdale as Ross Kirk she played
Jasmine Thomas he's also known for his
role on Gavin & Stacey as fingers where
he co-starred with other fellow Doctor
Who alumni James Corden who played Craig
in the lodger and closing time and
Johanna page who played Queen Elizabeth
during the 50th anniversary special
because Radio Times is calling him a new
companion we can assume that at some
point he'll join Clara and the doctor in
the TARDIS
during William Hartnell's run the same
thing happened to teachers Barbara
Wright and Ian Chesterton in that
scenario they were really following the
doctors granddaughter Susan Foreman
though so now let's talk about how he's
going to fit into the group I'm sure
everyone is going to rush to Netflix to
re-watch season one to see what right
and Chesterton's run looked like all
joking aside I do think that Moffat is
trying to pay homage to season 1 with
the dynamic and maybe even the tone a
little Peter Capaldi won't be playing a
version of William Hartnell it'll be his
own original take on the character but
we as who viens will see the
similarities a stern older doctor with a
young eager companion joined by a
curious scholar practically in terms of
Anderson actually boarding the TARDIS I
think it'll be something like series 5
where Rory was part of the story for the
entire year but wasn't in all the
episodes especially the first half of
the series does this mean that by series
9 Anderson's character pink will board
the TARDIS full time just like Rory did
during series 6 though it's too hard to
predict as we don't know how long Jenna
Louise Coleman will stay and if she does
leave we don't know if Anderson will
take over as full-time solo companion I
really do hope they both stay on for
series 9 because it took me almost all
of series 5 just to get used to Arthur
Darvill Rory mostly because he was the
butt of all of Amy and the doctor's
jokes until he changed into that
Centurion character let's hope that pink
does not run afoul of the Daleks because
the doctors track record with companions
is a little spotty we
actually better cross our fingers this
will be the fourth time and dr. whose
history coal Hill School has been
heavily featured the first being with
Wright in Chesterton than with eighths
and the Seventh Doctor in remembrance of
the Daleks than with the eighth doctor
in Samantha and the eighth doctor's book
story and most recently with Jenna
Louise Coleman during the 50th
anniversary special what is his
relationship with Clara going to be like
though it's probably not gonna be like
Rory and Amy just because that was
already done so recently when I first
saw him I thought of Mickey just because
he has such a close relationship with
Rose but it was always implied that he
fancied her it didn't help that no Clark
also took this picture with Jenna Louise
Coleman while she was filming series 8
he said that he was just visiting
because he was nearby but all you
conspiracy theorists can have some fun
with it seriously though I am expecting
series 8 to be less of a relationship
comedy than Matt Smith's run had become
especially with the addition of River
Song who's also rumored to make an
appearance
the real question now is which episode
Anderson will debut and if not episode 1
and what his arc is going to be and if
there going to be any other new
companions after him the good news is is
that we have learned some things about
episode 1 though so here they are it
takes place in Victorian London and will
feature the Paternoster gang maybe even
Jack the Ripper as one of the villains
I'd say that Anderson could be like a
history professor or an expert on the
subject but really isn't the doctor
supposed to be the universe's greatest
historian having lived through most of
it himself Ben Wheatley the director
said in a recent interview this month
that he hopes his episodes episodes 1 &
2 will be aired as soon as July last
year the BBC has said that fall 2014
would be their expected start date but
it's totally possible that they could
air the first episode at San Diego Comic
Con early last year they only brought
two short clips for the 50th anniversary
and adventure in space and time but they
have screened full episodes early in the
past I was actually able with myself to
see the first episode of series 7 at
WonderCon last year the timing was very
close to the official premiere so it's
possible that we will see new episodes
as soon as I guessed if they do screen
in episode early at Comic Con now it's
your turn let me know what are your
reactions to Anderson's casting and what
kind of a companion do you think he's
going to be I'll be posting that Q&A
video in the next day or two so be sure
to subscribe to get it feel free to ask
me any other question about series that
you want it doesn't have to be about
Anderson right now click here to get my
top 10 for
see pics for new Time Lords and click
here to learn more about series 8 thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tonight
high fives
you